live on Sky News how is your English
hopeful hi my English is awful
why are you here here yeah Oh in London
well in London for the Fenner of
ribeirão Preto yeah
and here for the Royal baby okay because
there is true events in London today
one it will be and the other is a you
know in France
Jeanne said speak a lot of royal baby oh
yes very very popular and what were you
singing earlier singing it is a single
one the into law when the player player
comes to the stadium it is
I'm clear communicator yeah just say
this that's what you French people say
and we love it
can you translate your never singing
what were they singing for earlier the
teacher corners kiddo gear oh we have a
Oh what's the word to that when you when
you support a team man you have one two
three
Wow and all that everybody screams the
same thing at the same time okay so
you're chanting yes
chanting and yes for too long but I as a
French journalist come from Cal morphine
also I'm supportive do you think you
could possibly do the song for us again
oh I don't know you get on your a knows
it but to the festival
oh why not because I'm being telling you
let's go chat with them with Maude Maude
over here works for for seem like a
thank you never leave yeah yeah more